I think what's really exciting about
this genre in particular is it's kind of
the place where sex and power and class
all kind of they they all reached a kind
of point of Crisis and
so the aristocracy and the katten family
felt like a really interesting way of
looking at our relationship with the
things that we want
this is always about sort of upending
our expectations of the country house
genre and usually you'll have a grand
sweeping drone shot of the house here we
reveal it in this just quite static kind
of block of intimidation with his little
tiny wheelie bag trying to work out how
to navigate the
gate I think you approach that house no
matter how many times you walk towards
them Gates you're going to feel the same
thing it's a dominant presence and it's
it's almost telling you to go away
there's something so jarring about you
know the expectation of this enormous
building and the formality of the Butler
and the footman and the the scale of it
and the sort of history of
it Mr quick follow
me coming into a place like this is I
think for anyone really here but even if
this place wasn't this big but just
coming into a setting or family like
that again I'd feel like Oliver he's not
going to fit in
this is a character in itself this place
and there's many shades to it wow just
wow when you get to set and you're in
this house that's your house and little
Barry rocks up with his you know his
suitcase and then uh Duncan comes in and
is cruel it's very easy to grab him and
kind of find this flow in what you do
it's almost like Felix kind of
orchestrates the
house thank God you're here Duncan I'll
show to his room Don't Worry Oliver try
not to be too terrified of Duncan Duncan
stop being so frightening in front of my
friends well I'll try come on manix come
on he's terrified oh he's all right he's
just the emphasis was kind of on the
Lash way that he owns the space the kind
of nonchalant way that he talks about
these kind of pieces of Art and
artifacts that like haven't been seen by
the world you know there's these
incredibly rare books and ancient pianos
and paintings and he's kind of just
going through them like they're nothing
Green Room Garden some hideous
Rubin broken
piano uh blue room and I think that's
what the the kind of emphasis was on
that's why the camera is kind of buried
behind his back everything everything is
so expensive and so lavish and so rich
that it's worth nothing to Felix it's
quite you know intimidating and this
massive Place dripping in stuff from the
1700s and that it's if you kind of watch
the scene you see I'm not really fully
focused on what's In in the rooms it's
more about how Felix is moving in front
of me this is the long Gallery uh dead
re dead relies my daddy's old Teddy
Shakespeare's folio we always wanted one
long kind of steady cam shot to take us
through the house to get that immediate
sense of geography in the end we ended
up cutting into it a little for Oliver's
reaction but I think it's got such a
fantastic sense of space and what it
does is really does a huge amount of
exposition for us
in terms of getting to know the like
terrain
[Music]
and your
room
wow already from the beginning of the
film we kind of want the audience I
think to wander a little bit like is
there something with this house and the
house is sort of a character by itself
and does it hide a lot of mysteries and
in a painterly way what you wanted to
refer
to it would fit best if the Interiors
felt kind of Barack like the Barack
painters dramatic sunlight coming
through the windows but lots of dark uh
space negative space around usually
we're looking at a house like this
through a lens of a certain formality
and emerald just didn't want that
Emerald wanted to show how people are
living in these houses okay you know and
how there's mess and Detroit us a Family
Life Emerald is showing you this is the
life of living in a stately home and
it's the outsider coming into this world
who is the audience's guide through that
you see all of these people through his
eyes anything else I should know about
no no just be yourself I love you it's
relaxed I promise we'll be in the
library
library meeting the family is always a
complicated thing because the
introduction of characters on screen is
like one of the most important decisions
you make you know and especially when
you're dealing with like a lot of like a
lot of big stars being introduced for
the first time because you're wanting to
make sure that you're becoming familiar
with people quickly but you're also kind
of giving them the kind of introduction
that they
deserve we meet the family as he's kind
of walking towards them so we are aware
that he's hearing what they're saying
they probably don't have rehab in
Liverpool no gosh no no I can't imagine
they do so everybody just goes to ruin I
suppose where is Liverpool I think it's
on the sea isn't it think where's
Liverpool uh North North yes the way
that they talk about it is just so kind
of vois and cruel and both his parents
were dealing God and his mother's are
drunk I mean babies can be really
affected traumatized they come out
drunk when you're making any kind of
film both you the audience and you the
filmmakers are at each other's mercy and
so it's quite fun to be able to sort of
um lean in on that tension when you're
making something go on come and sit by
me
c beautiful and that's film making at
what stage do we the filmmakers decide
to give the audience what they want and
at what stage do we decide to take it
away I I played with I think two or
three different ways into it and then
what made us laugh most what seemed to
show the family off in their sort of
delicious ghastliness some people find
the family really lovable and some
people find them grotesque I think
they're grotesquely lovable like that's
what I love about them is that right
that he had to put his fingers down his
mother's throat to make her sick fary
that's private stuff well you told us in
confidence and then he catches the eye
of visha Kat and we meet her for the
first time where she's pretending to
read a book and so we had a lot of fun
um trying to choose the fake book she
was going to read I think in the end
she's reading like a Spanish dictionary
from like the 18th century has venisha
seen you yet oh my God she'll die she's
been draping herself all around the
house all day hoping you'll come across
her as it were do stop poor boys only
just arrived these are people I admire
and these are top quality actors
actresses and they're just fascinating
at what they do and it's kind of
intimidating in a way you know that I
wanted to kind of use I wanted to use
that in the scene and I kind of stay
separate to them on that day as well H
consciously you know I wanted to kind of
go in
and just be in front of them see where
it
goes I was sitting there for 2 hours
with richardy Grant and we're just
laughing you know eating sweeties and
laughing laughing laughing we're all in
there just sort of talking and
waiting for Barry to come and then when
he arrives you know we've all been in
there for you know an hour setting the
shut up and everything so it really was
this like who is this you know this is
on in our family kind of thing and here
he is no we were just talking about you
don't be silly we in this wide finally
of this crammed kind of very Eccentric
Family which despite all of this space
everyone's just kind of shoved in this
room and the jeros of of going through
the king's bedroom and the blue room
into this books piled high furniture on
top of each other it plays with the kind
of weird extremities that you constantly
find yourself in in saltburn what
beautiful eyes oh how wonderful yeah I
told you it wasn't a minger oh but
darling you're kind about everyone one
you can't be trusted Oliver I have a
complete and utter horror of ugliness
ever since I was very young I don't know
why because you're a terrible person
when olle arrives her guard rails go up
immediately that you know this could be
a threat to her existence Pamela doing
would you go and find Annie and ask
about
te what I love so much about this scene
as well is you just see how quickly an
acolyte gets dumped so the moment that
Oliver comes in poor dear Pamela is sent
off to get tea and she knows immediately
what that means what that means is off
your
pop there's some new prey in town they
read people on a social level they see
if you belong if you do not belong who's
boring who's okay who's who needs to go
who's overstay they're welcome it's all
social codes and Oliver understands
psychological codes and that is what
makes the film very very
interesting that's the thing about this
family and making this world is is we
all need to kind of get why you would do
almost anything to stay there nothing
shocks me Oliver absolutely nothing tell
me everything